already the nhs is struggling to cope
with the demands of winter the queue of
ambulances outside new cross hospital in
wolverhampton typical of emergency
departments across the country
now the challenge of offering all adults
a booster by the end of the year means
something has to give
our intention at the present time is to
continue with our elective programme of
work we need to review that obviously
daily depending on what the demand is in
terms of booster vaccines so as we look
and see what sort of activity could be
stood down we look at what priority it
is and there are different priorities of
surgery the government says that
cancer appointments for example won't be
cancelled
can you say with certainty that there'll
be no cancer appointments cancelled
i don't think you would ever want to say
you can never say never certainly our
intention at the moment is not to cancel
any cancer appointments
with a record number almost 6 million
people on waiting lists for non-urgent
hospital treatment in england any
cancellations will add to a growing
backlog
for many patients some of whom may have
waited a long time for appointments and
may have faced cancellations in the past
it'll now be a nervous few weeks as they
wait to see if things can go ahead as
planned
patients like dawn partridge who has
epilepsy her consultant appointment in
preston cancelled she won't be able to
see a doctor now until after christmas
uh they just said that my neurologist
wasn't available and i got told january
but in all honesty i'm not holding my
breath on it because like say the
this is the third time the appointment's
been cancelled now i've not been seen in
probably 12 months now
gps running vaccine clinics now
inundated with people booking boosters
good afternoon alfred square's
vaccination centre debbie speaking i'm a
health
they accept it'll be even harder to get
a gp appointment for anything non-urgent
in the next few weeks the pressures over
the last few months have been
pretty intense and as you say
access has been
you know particularly difficult issue
for
uh for patients
um
there's quite a lot of work
going on to try uh and and manage that
but
as we tried to do that this vaccine
situation comes along
delivering vaccines that the scale and
pace required will undoubtedly add more
pressure to a health service that's
already stretched like never before
becky johnson sky news wolverhampton